[Music]
threat has been detected a good analogy
for a virus would be similar to termites
they can be in your house right now you
don't even know about it when you
finally find out is when it's too late
on March the 6th when your computer
turns on it realizes it's that day and
will start to wreck information on your
hard disk remember 10 to 20 years ago
when we were all scared about getting a
computer virus we would pay for
antivirus protection from companies like
McAfee and the Norton just so that we
wouldn't get a trojan virus but somehow
despite all our efforts getting a virus
was often an inevitability and then we'd
have to put our computers into safe mode
delete recently downloaded files run
virus scans and hope and pray that the
computer will actually boot up the next
time and that no data was corrupted or
lost but nowadays the thought of a
computer virus destroying our computer
rarely crosses our mind in fact many of
us have completely stopped purchasing
external antivirus protection yet our
computer experience is better than ever
and we don't even have to deal with
those slow virus skins so did computer
viruses just to get eradicated like
polio or smallpox but wait that can't be
true because we still hear about data
breaches and hacks all the time so
clearly computers and codes still have a
bunch of vulnerabilities but then what
happened to traditional computer viruses
before we answer why viruses are no
longer a big threat for most of us we
have to understand how viruses work in
the first place computer viruses have
been around for a long time with the
first one called creeper dating back to
1971. the mechanics of the virus was
extremely simple once the virus was
placed inside a local hard drive it
would just keep replicating itself until
the given computer ran out of space and
became an operational at this point the
virus would taunt the user with the
message I'm the creeper Catch Me If You
Can fortunately the creeper wasn't hard
to catch because it came along with an
antidote called Reaper this is because
creeper wasn't actually designed with
malicious intent it was simply supposed
to demonstrate basic computer
vulnerabilities and how the shortfalls
could be addressed but the days of
benign experimental viruses didn't last
long as soon as computers became
generally available a new subset of
people called hackers started trying to
reverse engineer code and we started
seeing much more deadly viruses this
included the first real world virus
called brain in 1986. unlike creeper
brain didn't just aim to waste your hard
drive space brain was trying to corrupt
your computer and it did this by
latching onto your boot disk from there
brain would move your real boot sector
to another location and the market as
bad in the meantime it would overwrite
your original boot sector with the virus
making it impossible to boot the
computer the next prominent computer
virus Michelangelo appeared in 1991 and
it worked in a very similar fashion but
with a unique twist instead of
corrupting the computer as soon as
Michelangelo made contact Michelangelo
would wait until March 6th of every year
this way no one would really know how
much the virus had spread and then
suddenly on March 6th the virus would
overwrite the first 100 sectors with its
zeros and everyone would be screwed over
at the same time this strategy was
especially effective as the virus would
end up infecting 20 000 compute but the
next virus was so much bigger that
Michelangelo would look like a school
project ironically though the next virus
cih was developed by a university
student and launched in 1998. the motive
well the University student wanted to
put over confident software engineers in
their place and I think it's safe to say
that that goal was destroyed once cih
made it to a user's computer it would
overwrite the hard drive the boot sector
and even the BIOS similar to
Michelangelo cih was designed to remain
dormant for one month before starting
its Rampage but when the virus was
triggered it was absolutely deadly cih
would end up infecting a whopping 60
million computers and causing 1 billion
dollars worth of damage for the first
time computer viruses weren't just a
nuisance they were an actual
International threat and this threat
would only get even bigger with the
internet up until now the main corporate
spreading viruses were shared floppy
disks but let's just say the internet
was much more viral the first prominent
internet virus came in 1999 and it was
called Melissa Melissa was distributed
through email and once you received
Melissa it would automatically be sent
to 50 of your contacts fortunately
Melissa wasn't malicious some would even
call it a social service as Melissa was
simply Distributing passwords to adult
websites but at successor I love you in
2000 wasn't nearly as kind on the
surface I love you was a simple text
file that was spread through email but
behind the scenes it was actually a
Visual Basic script or a VBS that could
overwrite office image and audio files
and thanks to the virality of the
internet it would spread to 50 million
computers in less than 10 days this
marked the beginning of the peak
computer virus era but within the next
10 to 15 years this fear would disappear
as if it never existed in the first
place so what in in the world happened
well as you saw with all those viruses
there's only two ways that they can
spread it share storage devices and the
internet the first medium was naturally
eliminated thanks to the internet now
that people could email each other there
was less of a need to share floppy disks
or USB sticks if you were going to use
an external storage device it was more
than likely just for personal use so the
storage device medium kind of died out
on its own but the internet medium was
much harder to address a lot of this
process simply consisted of small
improvements to secure you over a long
time period but there was a pinpointable
event that leaped forward Internet
Security and that was the ditching of
Internet Explorer back in 2004 the
market share of Internet Explorer peaked
at 95 percent most of you probably
remember I.E as the slow buggy crappy
browser but it was much worse than just
that as it also had serious security
vulnerabilities you see it I.E didn't
just allow for execution of a JavaScript
which is the standard for websites I.E
also allowed for the execution of VB
scripts which gave the browser access to
the computer this Probably sounds like a
stupid idea but there was reason for it
ideally this would allow websites to
accomplish much more advanced tasks as
they had access to the computer but this
also meant that they could accomplish
much more nefarious tasks and that's
exactly what happened Microsoft didn't
really do much about this other than
putting out a tutorial on how to disable
vbscript execution but let's be honest
this was not something that the average
user was ever going to do something that
the average user did do though was ditch
Internet Explorer and move to Chrome
unlike Microsoft Google didn't not
support vbscriptive which made these
viruses virtually useless this meant
that the storage device medium and the
direct from browser medium were
effectively cut off which left us with
just the downloading medium the
eradication of this medium M came down
to multiple factors starting with
constant updates before 2010 there was
really no such thing as regular updates
you got a version of Windows when you
bought your PC and you would have this
version up until you got another PC but
moving into the 2010s constant
over-the-air updates became a thing and
while these updates somehow always
happened at the worst time is possible
they did wonders for computer security
viruses no longer had ears on end to
keep exploiting the same bugs and
glitches as soon as a virus was
discovered companies were able to patch
it and send out an update we should also
mention that company started taking
cyber security much more seriously
between 2010 and 2018 alone cyber
security spending rocketed from 27.4
billion dollars to 66 billion dollars
these companies build out entire cyber
security departments filled with
extraordinarily talented and well paid
engineers at the Microsoft for example
security analysts are paid 272 thousand
dollars on average speaking of
compensation companies also started
Distributing hackers by straight up
bribing them Google for instance offers
one million dollars if you can hack
Chrome similarly apple is offering a
million and a half if you can hack the
iPhone and these companies end up paying
out several people every single year and
in return you're able to prevent
exploits that may have harmed hundreds
of millions of users in the meantime
users have also gotten much more tech
savvy when it comes to protecting their
devices we should also mention that our
internet usage has also become much more
focused while we all spend more time
than ever on the internet virtually all
of our usage has to do with reputable
companies and Brands like Google
Facebook Microsoft Apple and Amazon so
the chances that were even exposed to a
virus is significantly lower than 10 to
20 years ago and when you put all of
these factors together you get the virus
free era
foreign
viruses are completely gone though the
number of Bad actors and threats are
actually larger than ever and one of the
main reasons that we don't see viruses
affect us is because Bad actors no
longer Target everyday users back in the
day the only incentive of creating a
virus was to make a splash in the tech
scene and or expose vulnerabilities but
nowadays hacking is a lot more
profitable and I'm not talking about
selling your hacks to big name companies
I'm talking about using exploits to
steal loads of data and operate
International cyber crime rings that do
everything from creating fake IDs take
credit card fraud and this makes perfect
sense let's say you find a data exploit
in Windows after years of work would you
rather try to spread this virus amongst
everyday users and display some sort of
corny gotcha message or would you rather
Target an institution I mean the answer
is obvious is stealing the data of 100
million users from T-Mobile is
infinitely more valuable than corrupting
random people's PCS this information is
literally worth billions given that
you'll have to sell it through dark
Avenues you'll probably have to accept a
deep discount and sell it for hundreds
of millions but that's still 100 times
what Google is willing to pay you for
that exploit also even if you were going
for everyday people the goal wouldn't
not be to screw up your machine in fact
the goal would be the exact opposite as
you wouldn't even want the user to
notice ideally the virus should be able
to collect data permanently and then not
inhibit any functionality whatsoever if
you do this at scale you can have
constant streams of data from tens and
millions if not hundreds of millions of
people and thanks to cryptocurrency
hackers are able to transact insane
amounts of money with ease this one
hacker for example claims that he owns 7
billion dollars worth of bitcoin making
him the 369th richest person in the
world so while viruses no longer have
affect us directly there's still very
much a major threat
in the end we all remember computer
viruses as a symbol of computers
throughout the 2000s thanks to much
safer browsers constant updates art
security departments and much more Savvy
users traditional computer viruses have
become a thing of the past but this
isn't to say that cyber security threats
have been completely eliminated
altogether rather they've simply shifted
in their form and their motive viruses
today don't aim to slow down your
computer or corrupt it they aim to steal
your data and sell it for millions and
judging by the constant data leaks that
we see on a regular basis that looks
like there is still a long way to go
but hey at least we don't have to deal
with Trojan viruses and safe mode
anymore when was the last time that you
had a computer virus comment that down
below also drop a like if you're glad
that we're past traditional viruses and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community such as future video
ideas and to consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one